Michigan is urging residents in several  counties to cancel or postpone outdoor  events it comes amid the state's worst  outbreak of a potentially deadly  mosquito-borne virus in more than a  decade there have been seven confirmed  human cases of eastern equine  encephalitis in Michigan three people  have died at least 20 cases have been  reported in five states totally  terrifying that's why when I see my SWAT  oh yeah yeah I don't care what they  watch out I believe in all living  creatures get on get you to Michigan you  might have that virus that's right well  it is rare to catch it but it is one of  the most deadly diseases that mosquitoes  carry so be careful right there